three teenage boys have been killed in
an Israeli air raid on the border
between Israel and the Gaza Strip after
another week of clashes their funerals
for victims were held on Tuesday with
relatives gathering in Gaza City
families of the three teen victims
claimed they were only in the area to
set nets for catching birds was falling
- that the Israeli army claimed the boys
behavior in fact was suspicious as they
saw it troop spotted a squad of three
suspects approaching the border under
the cover of darkness in a crouched and
suspicious manner the three operated in
a way that was identical to previous
incidents in which terror operatives had
placed explosive devices in the same
location well I got reaction from both
sides of this latest incident in Gaza
take three young boys who unfortunately
were killed but they were clearly
approaching an open fire zone that had
been established by Hamas six months ago
tremble is any close associates of those
victims children victims confirmed to
media outlets that very children were
doing a routine work or a teen activity
simply putting up traps for Bates for
bears
so if I was a parent I wouldn't let my
child anywhere near that border fence
and the only reason that they were near
that hostile border fence is to either
cut the fence or plant explosives or
kill or kidnap Israelis it's the only
reason there's no other logical reason
for them to be there
the Israelis always he claims that they
don't target civilians well in fact many
civilians have been victims for Israeli
army actions throughout the region the
idea at the Israel Defense Forces is the
only army in the Middle East and I would
argue one of the only armies if the only
army in the world that has multiple
layers of confirmation before it issues
open fire orders on anybody the latest
incident in which a three Palestinian
the children were killed in the Buddha
was a part of the of this repeated
history by the Israeli army terms of the
buffer zone Israel has been erecting the
buffer zone this comes actually against
the well of the people who live in this
these areas especially the farming
community
you